today we mourn the passing of a
remarkable sovereign
it is a deep private loss for the royal
family and our first thoughts are with
them at this time
the nation shares in their grief
Queen Elizabeth II created a special
personal relationship with us all
a relationship based on service and
Devotion to her country
nobody under the age of 70 has known
anything other than Queen Elizabeth II
on the throne
for the vast majority of us the late
Queen has been simply
the queen
the only Queen
Above All Else
Our Queen
as we mourn her loss we should also
treasure her life
our longest serving and greatest ever
monarch
above the clashes of politics she stood
not for what the nation fought over
but what it agreed upon
in crisis she reassured us reminding us
that we are all part of something that
stretches back through time
a symbol of the best of us
I saw it for myself when I let the crown
prosecution service
every time I had the privilege to meet
the late Queen she would ask the most
searching questions because she wanted
to understand the lives and struggles of
her people
and as Britain changed rapidly around
her this dedication became the Still
Point
of our turning world
an example that taught us that whatever
the challenges we Face the values of
service always endures
and the obvious love the late Queen
displayed for Britain the British people
gave back in return
that is why there is such an outpouring
of grief Across the Nation today
as there is across the Commonwealth to
which the lake Queen was so devoted
around the world people are united in
mourning
and United in celebrating her life
this togetherness is a reminder of what
she achieved
a reminder of our shared values values
which I know will be upheld by her
beloved Son Charles
our new king
so as our great Elizabethan era comes to
an end
we will honor the late Queen's memory
by keeping alive the values of Public
Service she embodied
for 70 years Queen Elizabeth II stood as
the head of our country
but in spirit
she stood amongst us